David, should Bernie or Warren, if they are
the nominees, consider a more centrist or
a more progressive running mate.
So when picking a running mate, often there
are three um, factors that are brought up,
ideology of the running mate, the w what region
of the country they are from and their demographic,
uh, sort of characteristics.
Ideology would be if you are progressive,
do you go with another progressive or do you
go with like a centrist or more, a more moderate
region would be if you are like Bernie and
Warren from the Northeast.
Warren, you know, talks about being from Oklahoma
or whatever.
But Jesus, Massachusetts Senator, if you're
a Northeast elected official, do you go with
another Northeast elected official or like
a West coast elected official, which is similar?
Or do you try to get someone from the Midwest
or from the South or something like that?
And then demographics, if you are, for example,
70 years of age or older as both Bernie, I
believe, Warren 70.
Right?
And Bernie's, uh, older than that.
Um, do you go with a younger candidate or
do you go with someone else who is in their
seventies?
If you are a man, do you go with a woman?
If you are white, do you go with someone who's
not white?
So on and so forth.
It's very appealing to try to round out the
ticket with someone who is different but complements
what you bring.
So if you're a progressive, bring a moderate
so that you bring moderates into the ticket.
If you are from the Northeast, bring someone
from somewhere else so that you have more
geographic, uh, a geographically diverse background.
If you are, whatever racial, demographic,
religious, demographic, gender, age, whatever,
you bring someone different to appeal to different,
different people.
I actually think that it's far simpler than
this.
You need a vice president who is not a going
to become the story and B, make any gaps.
Mike Pence was perfect for Donald Trump in
this sense.
He stayed completely out of the way.
Who remembers anything that Mike Pence did?
I have no recollection of the debate that
Mike Pence had with Tim Kaine.
By the way, we could talk about the choice
of Tim Kaine as as maybe not a good one, but
that's for another story.
Pencil is like a statue.
Whenever Trump's talks, Pence is completely
motionless.
The guy knows how to blend into the background.
If Donald Trump ends up in Peached and convicted,
maybe Mike pencil end up as president of the
United States, and that's priority number
one.
Someone who's not going to get in the way
or do gaffs or whatever.
In addition to that, if you can find someone
that is a compliment ideologically, regionally
or demographically, that also helps.
That was also Pence, Pence and evangelical
conservative.
Very different than Trump, a more pro-business
Republican, regionally Trump from New York
city Pence from Indiana, demographically.
Okay.
I mean, they're both just white dudes.
So maybe, maybe there's less about that, but
it worked.
So as crazy as it is, the model for who to
choose is what Donald Trump did with Mike
Pence.
Someone who won't get in the way or become
the story or GAF in a way that would hurt
you or, or could cost you the election.
And if there is some benefit to some of the
other characteristics, all the better.
I would go away from making the primary choice
about progressive candidate should have a
progressive running mate and we're going all
in on progressivism or progressive candidate
should have a moderate running mate so that
you can appeal to both moderates and progressives.
This is going to be a turnout election.
This is going to be an election of how do
they face up against Donald Trump, particularly
during the debates and with the nicknames
and everything else.
That's where I would prioritize my thinking.
And if you get some benefit along the other,
uh, paths, uh, ideology, ideologically complimentary,
uh, geographically complimentary or demographically
complimentary, all the better.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Hat's bonus show on Friday.
Join pacman.com sign up for a membership and
get instant access to the bone, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].